[Music]
so we'll look a little more in this
first area of the debate at this
question then of what objective
knowledge is and if we're I think
everybody in a way agrees that no one's
making a very very strident case for
this monolithic adamantine knowledge
that we would all reach as a final goal
so cheter I wanted to turn to you in
terms of and respon to Rupert's remarks
about you know the the kind of reductive
process as well because you're dealing
both um as you were saying with sort of
denying your expectations of a subject
and also with looking at billions and
billions of electrons and looking at
this very small area so there's that
question as well for you is that to you
a kind of reality that you're seeing
those those very very small electrons
that you're looking at yeah actually
that's a really interesting question
because I think think that um there's
different ways of approaching science
one is uh reductionist and the other is
emergent I study emergent uh forms of um
uh physical phenomena so in the
reductionist way indeed one would think
there's a theory of everything at some
point you're going to gather enough
information that you can write this
Theory and then you will be able to
predict everything in the universe um
that's a very different wave so there
indeed it's about reducing everything to
its fundamentals and once you know what
the fundamental is you can build
everything back up uh what I do is
emergent forms of uh physics which is
very different and so there what we say
is um well the the way we approach um
doing experiments discovering new
phenomena is that trillion trillions of
electrons uh as many as the stars in the
observable universe um in a milligram of
material when all of these interact
together um much the same way as you
know all of us interact together or
neurons in the brain interact together
it's absurd to think that a collective
phenomena can be reduced into the
constituent particles and that those
will explain what is happening
collectively instead what emergence is
is that when these trillion trillions of
electrons come together what we observe
macroscopically
is completely different from how each of
the single particles behave so yes
absolutely I think reductionist ways of
knowing of doing science um I would
strongly push back against because I
don't think that's that's how knowing
occurs but I don't think that science is
reductionist I think emergence is
absolutely at the heart of what I do as
an experimental physicist I look at a
Quantum system with trillion trillion
electrons and when I measure it what
they collectively do is nothing like
what an individual electron does and
that is the portal to accessing new
Quantum forms of matter experimentally
so it doesn't have to be that one goes
to the realm of Beyond experiment and
necessarily mysticism to access emerging
forms of behavior those are access
physically experimentally thank you and
just a really quick followup I just
wanted to as you were talking about the
a counter and this Revelation within
quantum physics that the Observer
affects what's being observed so and is
that something then that you deal with
tangibly when you're researching is this
something that's affecting your
experimental process um yeah yeah that's
a really good question about um
encounter I think it's very much so
there's there's again two ways of
approaching how what what happens when
you do an experiment one is starting
with a model and the experiment being to
test the model so we all know when we
think we know something's going to
happen you'll find what it is you think
is going to happen so uh the idea that
ruper was talking about a Prejudice and
um self-confirmation bi is often true
just because when you start with the
model you expect that is what is going
to be experimentally
realized very often that's what you will
find because you throw away all the rest
of the information that is actually
being um being given to you by the
experiment um on the other hand um what
is what the encounter is about is if you
go and saying it is unknown yes I have
prejudices where wherein I think this
might happen but actually I need
to um I need to be attuned to what is
happening in the experiment knowing full
well that what I thought is going to
happen is likely not going to and it
always it always deviates in a way I
didn't think it would so even if I go
and thinking yeah it's not going to do
what I think it's going to do I still
think it's going to deviate in a certain
way and what it actually does is
completely different so that's what I
mean by the encounter is if you go in
knowing that it is an unknown beyond
your
imagination then that's when you
actually encounter what it is that's
happening yes great thank you Tommy I
wanted to come in because you were
talking about the rational tradition and
I wonder if that's a way to talk about
knowledge that in a way the totalizing
claims being made by rationalism you or
the rational method were what you were
questioning you weren't saying let's
dispense with it all together no but
there's need for gaps in that is that
part yeah I mean we have to understand
that human knowledge both what we take
to be an accumulation of facts or
everything we know uh is incomplete and
whatever our best tools our best way of
inquiring into the world is will always
be limited so in in doing so it gets rid
of this kind of uh strong claim of
objectivity right because objectivity
presumes that there is a a form of
knowledge or reality that's unchanging
that is fixed static and that regardless
of your social position your location
Etc that you would have knowledge of
this now the rationalist are going to
argue this is through rational
philosophical processes medievalists and
others like Plato would say this is
through intuition trying to grasp the
forms this kind of formal reality that
by the way exists in kind of this ether
well above anything we perceive right
and you have people today that make very
similar arguments uh even in trying to
question the objective epistemological
tradition things like standpoint of
epistemology seem to interact with the
world saying that your social location
gives you an almost immediate knowledge
of your experience and the truth behind
that and I would want a much more
mediated process because if we
understand that knowledge itself is
limited that we're trying to grasp
something that is very much contextual
something that's changing something that
if you did the same thing in a different
location would have a completely
different outcome effect or or even
Catalyst um that requires us to have a
certain kind of humility and I dare not
say the word relativism because I think
that's a bad it's a it's a bad way of
understanding this kind of Gap that we
have in human epistemology but it is
something that tries to get us to
understand that just because we want to
understand one outcome of knowledge or
one notion of Truth uh doesn't mean that
we can grasp it and even if we can
identify certain patterns of reality
knowing that every time you do X it
tends to lead to Y that doesn't mean
that it's always going to lead to Y and
part of the part of the arrogance of the
western tradition is that in assuming
that we've had reason and we've produced
why a 100 or a thousand times s and that
it will always be why is that it misses
the gap of that one time that one
existential qualifier where it won't be
why and rather than admitting that's an
error and takes us to A Whole New Field
of understanding different ways of
knowing or understanding why X doesn't
cause why we see that as an error
mistake or dare I say people who ared to
that because they're not rational right
that's the problem that's the problem
with both presupposing that we know what
knowledge is that we have an
accumulation of various x's and that the
process by which we get to X's is
absolutely correct rather we have to
take a step back and say well maybe
there are tentative and there I say
culturological ways of formulating
knowledge different schemas by which
different social groups locations Etc
arrive at why or not yet why that are
still valid and in the western tradition
I find that it's very rare that we're
willing to engage that either
intuitively or as a prospect in the
history of philosophy or even
experimental thank you and we're going
to have in the next section we'll talk
more about that par dnamic as well
and rer before we turn to that I want to
turn to you because you've written in
the science delusion precisely about
what Tommy's describing really a a kind
of refusal to accept novel theories
within Western science and certain
prevailing assumptions with which you
disagree so could you talk more about
that um you know this this question what
happens when the scientific method
excludes entire
theories yes well there is this serious
problem in in in science that
um the the idea of scientific paradigms
a very well-known idea first put forward
by Thomas uh historian of science
is the idea there's a model of reality
at any given time and then in a
scientific revolution it's overthrown
and it's replaced by another model of
reality the classic example is the um
medieval idea that the planets go around
the earth and all the stars everything
goes around the earth replaced by the
idea the earth and the other planets are
going around the Sun the heliocentric
model which was a revolution in thought
and Darwin's evolutionary theory was a
revolution in thought now the only
trouble is that Coon's idea of of
scientific revolutions um so you might
think well these revolutions each ones
are sort of opening up but actually
what's actually happened in science is
that one sort of dictatorship or
totalitarian systems being replaced by
another other and the idea has been that
there's a global kind of science that
applies everywhere in the world the
dominant Paradigm for the last 150 years
has been mechanistic
materialism um which is what I discuss
in my book The Science delusion uh
basically the idea that matter is the
only reality Consciousness is derived
from matter the mind is nothing but the
activity of the
brain God's nothing but an idea in human
minds and therefore inside human heads
um mechanistic materialism has come to
dominate all science over the entire
world if you study science in Africa in
South America in China in India it's the
same science that's taught in textbooks
here um the idea there's no one thought
system has ever conquered the whole
world in the way that science has done
Christian missionaries tried to convert
everyone to Christianity and failed uh
but scientific missionaries have
converted virtually every country in the
world to mechanistic materialism at
least when they're talking about science
and so uh one of the problems has been
this view has become so dominant so
dogmatic that it excludes inquiry within
science holds back inquiry in many areas
of science as I show in my book I can't
go into the details now because there
isn't time uh but it's become a very
restrictive framework and I think one
way forward taking out one of Tommy's
points is have a more pluralistic
approach and I think this should apply
in science to if there were more funding
agencies pursuing quite different
agendas even different National Science
policies uh I think we'd get a richer
and more interesting science for example
if in India there was a really big
emphasis on studying things that Indians
know a lot more about than we do in
Western countries like the nature of
conscious States the way that
physiological States can be changed
through breathing practices as in as
many yogis do and there are some studies
of this but it's very Niche and in in
the background there's a great deal we
could learn about human physiology and
Consciousness uh through serious
research in science but I worked in
India as a scientist and I found that
most of my colleagues there were not at
all interested in local phenomena like
that they wanted to get papers published
in nature and and and Science and do
science the way it was done in the W cuz
that's what gives Prestige so I think
that there's um a much greater pluralism
would be much better for Science and and
in fact what we should realize it's not
science it's the Sciences there are lots
of different Sciences each with their
own procedures but at the moment they
are unified by this mechanistic
materialist Paradigm which we need to
grow out of to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I a.tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest
ideas